الحصول على لقاح covid19 من هنا
إلى هنا ليس بالمهمة الصغيرة ،
فهو يتطلب سلسلة مصممة بعناية
تحافظ على القوارير شديدة البرودة في كل
خطوة على الطريق
أولاً ، تقوم الشركة المصنعة بتعبئة الجرعات
في
شاحنات يتم تخزينها في صندوق خاص
بحجم حقيبة
كل  معبأة بالجليد الجاف
ومجهزة بجهاز استشعار درجة الحرارة ومتعقب
نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS) ،
ثم تتجه الشاحنات إلى المطار
حيث يتم تعبئة الصناديق في
طائرات البضائع والركاب
نظرًا لأن حواجز الشحن بالطائرة غير
مبردة ، يجب
تخزين اللقاحات داخل تبريد خاص  يمكن
لبعض هذه الحاويات
ضبط درجة الحرارة بداخلها
بشكل فعال وإرسال تنبيه إذا حدث
خطأ ما بمجرد هبوط الطائرات في المطارات
، يتم تخزين بعض الحاويات في
مرافق تخزين تبريد خاصة
قبل التوجه إلى وجهتها التالية ،
ثم
تأتي شركات الشاحنات مثل فيديكس و
ستنقل UPS اللقاح إلى المستشفيات
والوجهات الأخرى من خلال
أعمال الرعاية الصحية في التخزين شديد البرودة  تقوم بإزالة القوارير
من الصناديق
ووضعها في المجمدات والبدء في
عملية تحويل القوارير إلى
حقن
للمساعدة في حماية الأشخاص من الإصابة بالمرض